wir blicken in die ukraine anfang juli
verkündete das russische
verteidigungsministerium eine operative
pause im don was aber diese
vermeintliche pause sie schafft für die
menschen in der ukraine eine völlig neue
furchtbare realität gleichzeitig nimmt
der kreml jetzt wieder ukrainische
städte im landesinneren ins visier und
am donnerstag feierte die russische
armee fünf marschflugkörper auf die
stadt wie nizza ein medizinisches
versorgungszentrum wurde dabei getroffen
mindestens 24 menschen sterben und mit
diesen angriffen will putin zeigen dass
niemand in der ukraine sicher ist und
einst wird deutlich er macht auch vor
zivilisten nicht halt
die wirtschaftlichen folgen des krieges
bekommen wir immer deutlicher zu spüren
die ampel rechnet sogar mit regionalen
notlagen das geht aus dem aktuellen
geheimen gas gipfel im kanzleramt hervor
das bedeutet konkret selbst wenn nicht
das ganze bundesgebiet von einer gas
notlage betroffen wird kann es in
einzelnen bundesländern knapp werden
deutschland wird auch im übernächsten
winter von russischem gas abhängig sein
und das heißt dass gas problem bleibt
noch bis 2024 und das gefühl vieler
menschen jetzt hat uns putin in der hand
und er entscheidet darüber ob wir im
winter frieren müssen darüber weil wir
sprechen mit unserem bild chefreporter
peter tiede bei uns im studio schönen
guten morgen peter einer bild umfrage
zeigt dass die deutschen eben diese
sanktionen nicht mehr gutheißen weil sie
eben angst haben im winter zufrieren was
sagst du dazu wird die deutschen
zweifeln daran ob die sanktionen gegen
russland tatsächlich wirken also es gibt
auf der anderen seite umfragen die sagen
da 67 prozent der deutschen gleichzeitig
für härtere maßnahmen gegen russland
sind also da gibt es widerspruch die
sagen er wir haben angst dass die
sanktionen nicht richtig wirken dazu
muss man aber wissen wir haben jetzt am
wochenende äußerungen gehabt von bayerns
ministerpräsident markus söder der zum
beispiel bezweifelt aber sagt dass die
deutschen fühlen dass russland nicht
rechtzeitig in die knie gezwungen und
die sanktionen seien dazu da gewesen
russland stelle in die knie zu zwingen
das stimmt zu schlicht und ergreifend
nicht denn die sanktionen sind erst
einmal eine bestrafung also der krieg in
europa führt wer sämtliche regeln bricht
er wird bestraft damit dass er zb unsere
technologie erst mal nicht mehr kriegt
also das worin wir stark sind das
bekommt er nicht mehr wir nehmen ihnen
bestimmte sachen auch nicht mehr ab das
gehört dazu das ist keine das ist nicht
als blitzkrieg geplant das soll keinen
kopfschuss für die für die russische
bevölkerung oder für die russische
gesellschaft sein da sind erst einmal
nur strafmaßnahmen und dann gibt es
andere sanktionen die sind gedacht als
persönliche sanktionen gegen diejenigen
die in russland diesen krieg planen und
ihnen durch für das sind die oligarchen
einige ordner die gleichen das sind aber
vor allem mitarbeiter im staatsapparat
und natürlich die ganze kamarilla rund
um wladimir putin also ja russland geht
in die knie ja wir stehen vor einem
gas-notstand aber b gehört mit dazu dass
wir diese abhängigkeit selber geschaffen
haben also das ist das lade mir putin
quasi den finger am abzug hat liegt
daran dass es deutsche politiker
zugelassen haben dass er den finger
überhaupt bis dahin bekommt warum ist es
jetzt wichtig an diesen sanktionen
festzuhalten also putin weiterhin die
stirn zu bieten ja steht da greifen weil
er alle regeln bricht weil er uns den
krieg mit erklärt hat also er führte
nicht nur krieg gegen gegen die ukraine
er führt ja sogar einen hunger krieg
gegen die heile welt der beschlagnahmten
der cloud weizen er nimmt quasi der
dritten welt und anderen staaten
wirklich die lebensgrundlage und das
ganz gezielt einfach nur um fluchtwelle
zu erzeugen die dann wieder nach europa
kommen die dann in den westen gehen und
wer gegen uns krieg führt der kann noch
nicht noch damit belohnt werden dass man
diese sanktion lockert wenn die
sanktionen will die sanktionen nicht
schnell genug wirken der muss härtere
sanktionen erlassen was muss die politik
jetzt ganz konkret tun damit wir im
winter nicht frieren müssen ja so ganz
ganz ganz normal für gas sorgen also dem
spruch gas geben ja das wird sich nicht
vermeiden lassen also wenn es hängt
immer alles daran ob nord stream 1 gibt
eine pipeline die ostsee noch aktiv ist
ob die weiter bestückt wird jetzt
momentan ist die in den
reparaturarbeiten den wird gewartet ganz
planmäßig die frage ist wird ende
nächster woche wieder angeschaltet oder
nächste woche wenn nicht dann haben wir
ein problem das muss dann gelöst wären
da muss man ganz klar sagen wer dafür
verantwortlich ist dass estland mehr
putin natürlich da sind aber auch die
früheren kanzler schröder und frau
merkel das ist der ehemalige
außenminister steinmeier die kann man
sich gerne wenden aber dann muss
natürlich ersatz her und da muss dafür
gesorgt werden dass schnellstmöglich gas
kommt und ich sag mal wie werden wird im
november und dezember schwierigkeiten
haben aber im januar der firma müssen
die probleme dann gelöst sein und das
geht nur über andere gaslieferverträge
das geht darüber dass rationiert wird
dann müssen wir uns wahrscheinlich
darauf einstellen dass wir in einigen
regionen deutschlands morgens mittags
abends warmes wasser haben und am rest
des tages mit strom erzeugen müssen aber
das ist das ist dann so das ist der
preis für freiheit und der preis für
frieden bei uns
vielen dank